the following is a presentation of the
St Louis chess club
hello everyone and Welcome to our show
we are here in St Louis at the Summer
Classic I'm yasserin this is I can't
believe it this is the first time we get
to work together wow thank you for
having me not at all are you kidding me
this is great hello everyone we're gonna
have a lot of fun today as we talk about
two tournaments the sick that are
ongoing now as I speak and let's talk
about it and Jump Right In tell us about
the fields we'll start with group a big
who's playing a uh players are Darius
ronak Elia Benjamin Aram Krishnan John
Praveen Nicholas and ABI manyo wonderful
field and uh Group B and Group B players
are Alex Slenderman Samuel lamanoso
Brendan Jacobson Andrew Hong al-shan
Justin Wong
look up the Salvage Akshay Chandra I'm
so glad you did all of that wow
that was terrific and tell us about that
oh
they're just down the road at the Chase
Park Plaza yeah at the hotel just down
the road from here uh where we are which
is in the St Louis chess club and
Scholastic Center and uh tell us begin
about the format of these two
tournaments uh the format of the two
tournaments are two 10 player round
robin 90 minutes for the 4 first 40
moves 30 minutes for the rest of the
game and 30 seconds increment throughout
the game I like these time controls I
really do I think they're very nice and
clean and tell us about the tournament
schedule
tournament schedule is we start the
first round today and it's gonna be till
August 10th without any rest says
straight through nine rounds in a row
we're gonna be uh exhausted I don't know
having a lot of fun huh
okay and tell us about the pairings
let's start with group a
today Ron like is playing against
one of playing against abhimanyu
Benjamin book is against Nicole Theodore
elianiznik against Oram hakapian and our
key matchup is Darius versus Krishnan
sasikara well let's just take a quick
Gander at those two players they're
really really strong their turn coming
in as terms of favors favorites pardon
me as we jump into the game
I look at this position that I have in
front of me I just go back a few moves
and as I go back I start to look at all
the moves that have happened and I
really get this awkward feeling that
we've been here before that the players
are following yeah something like the
precepts of theory and I wouldn't be
surprised if they are very familiar
because essentially
the whole board got hosed yeah right I
mean the bishop you want it more or less
if you if you believe you have an
advantages want to keep the bishop at
this position
I don't see anybody having a big
Advantage I agree with you it feels like
the balls still know the position
they're just trying to remember exactly
like Right Moves well indeed and as
we're looking at the position they're
already close to 20 moves in so it goes
to show how deep the opening is I'm just
surprised that they're taking their time
getting here right okay well uh we'll
keep an eye on this one and then to tell
let's take a look at well there they are
parents uh are Justin one against Akshay
Chandra but surren against elshon and
Armand against Andrew Hong look at the
Salvage against Simeon nominosov and
Brandon Jacobson is against Alexander
Linderman which are our key matchup and
let's start with this game absolutely
Brandon Jacobson heart of the U.S junior
championships where he competed in that
event Alex landerman has often times
played in the U.S Championship
which means that he's been in the 2650
close to 2700 class but he's been
slipping it's very very hard at the top
and as we jump into their game I've got
to tell you that for me personally yeah
I really don't like uh Linderman's
position at all I love the Bishops and
open position and we've got these two
just beautiful Bishops yeah obviously
they're lovely pressure on the B6 A6
bonds The Rook is about to slide over
and what is that not to like it's all
good for Brandon and whatever
Alex has done prior to this
don't do this at home don't try it
you're not going to be happy with the
outcome this is not this is not good for
Brandon so far oh it looks great
it looks uh terrific and as I just go
down through our list before we get to
do some serious analysis these these
players are going to be fighting what
are they fighting for oh prices are
fighting for great prizes for the group
a first prize is six thousand dollars
for the second one is four thousand
third one is three thousand dollars and
from the fourth to tens they still have
a great prizes and the total price fund
of the tournament is twenty two thousand
dollars very nice thank you St Louis
chess club and the price fund for the
group B group for the group b is first
prize is four thousand dollars second
prizes two uh two and a half thousand
dollars third prizes two thousand
dollars and the rest of the players also
get prizes and then total price of font
of the tournament is fourteen thousand
dollars wonderful thank you very nice uh
again uh thank you St Louis for all your
support and uh having these uh Fields
this is really really fun yeah we had
just looked at the game of Brandon in
London and we just thought you know this
one really good but now having said that
now I'm curious how did Black get such a
bad position I was curious about that
too I mean again Alex Linderman has a
reputation and a very deserved
reputation as a well a prepared uh
player he plays the Queen's campet since
it's something I play uh very often
myself this is a very tricky line for
black right either you equalize or
suffer whole game
well I did better than that I'm gonna
say if it was only about equalizing have
you ever beaten someone oh my God
right oh
well the the funny thing is a lot of my
victories of my many victories uh I
believe you mentioned in death report
um I uh I often times won
because my opponents felt hey I'm white
well pressure is one thing I'm white I
should be winning so if they had a
choice of a variation that might be say
very balanced they would go for the
riskier choice just because they thought
okay I'm supposed to be the one
president and they're oftentimes they
just you know went too far so so you're
scored psychologically more than
position wise
yeah
nice
uh first first question right here uh
the move Knight C4 again that that's
fine nobody's uh upset about that move
uh if there was a threat and I'm not
even sure it is a threat it's based on
the Move Knight D6 right so this is a
at this and by the way uh Brandon
I accepted a draw I wouldn't be uh
surprised if Brandon won we'll find out
very very very soon okay he's putting
the cases yeah okay so in this position
I would probably be inclined to play a
move like Queen to C7 just to protect
the square a castle it seems very
natural maybe but he wasn't on time
maybe there wasn't I I have a feeling
Brandon called him out of the opening
salmon and it looks logical but it feels
like maybe there are A3 before or
immediately prefer some opening trap
um
if I were in black shoes I'd probably be
inclined to lose the bishop that's not
developed in order to take command of
the C file something like Queen C7 but
he took
Bishop D okay this doesn't look terrible
but it feels like as you said we are
spending too much time on like
developing the bishop right well here he
just made an oversight I'm sure in my
way of thinking Knight C6 is a massive
threat and uh
well Queen B8 or Knight takes E5 to deal
with the threat he allowed this position
and this is where as we were coming on
the air we were talking about this bacon
and we were saying to each other uh no
no no and no right here is where we
stopped and you said you know what you
ask her if white ever gets in E3 E4
Bishop E3 yeah I think they're done
right we're done we're done he did he
got it in it feels like
Alex's
stop to the tournament and it Brandon
seems like on firm already he just ended
the Juniors tournament most probably
he's like more awake of like you know of
the situation right now than uh Alex
yeah maybe that's just no well sometimes
for me especially for me I want to say
that I was always victimized by jet lag
yeah I would be traveling across
the world mostly not just across country
but and the first few rounds oh some
pathetic examples but if I got through
the first few rounds then I was fine by
the way A3 A4 nothing else happened we
assume that this is where Lindeman said
I don't see a move just tell me what I'm
supposed to do the road it is crazy that
you cannot move a piece right The Rook
is Tethered to the protection of that
pawn yeah right probably these Knights
can't move
uh the only other well you could move
the Rook but again okay fine B6 is
hanging too well I kind of be happy
right like please take my phone on yeah
you know like okay I'm lost we're not
discussing that but I'm afraid you
resigned okay yeah now I'm afraid A5
even their five yeah it's crushing
that's that's the that's the one I'm
having a problem with now so it's like
you could move the Rook to get out of A5
but Rook takes him yeah now we look at
to the position deeper it's just like
it's yeah but okay it's about E4 version
you were right you got that you nailed
that right away let's just kind of go
around the tournament standing
tournament now that we're here just jump
into the game of Justin Wang and akshat
Chandra and by the way
this is not uh okay it comes out of an
open Sicilian looks like an English
attack
and the players reach a position
I actually like these positions for
black
which is kind of a strange thing to say
like white has done nothing wrong white
has this very nice wedgie you know and
if he ever could play Knight D4 B4 and
C5 like in a very nice way gets in that
yeah Knight to F5 and before C5 it's a
dream position right you but it takes a
lot of time
and in the meanwhile it's you you know
just look at the games of Magnus Carlson
he's got this very very annoying counter
play down the e-file oftentimes
associated with 94 the bishop pops out
the G5
or the bishop pops out to B6 and there
are issues uh that's the issue is this
uh position like in Knight g493 idea if
you are giving away your not in in your
in general giving away your black Bishop
but she did a black Squad Bishop right
which white did that's the issue after
exchanging some Central pawns you
suddenly have weak uh weak position
weaknesses for example I can play
B6 Queen C5 as you said right or if
Bishop comes to B6 itself right
immediately Knight jumps to G4 suddenly
you don't have an attack and black uh
black is faster exactly that's why I
think twice before I give a boy my
injury Bishop exactly the other thing
the the other reason that I do like
Black's position is one of King's safety
we just talked about the hidden
advantage in that previous game that
previous game the hidden Advantage which
wasn't so hidden by the way were the two
Bishops right wow that's really great
here the hidden advantage to me is that
Black's King is
frankly safer and the reason well
there's an F2 Pawn missing and you can
see that when the bishop goes to B6 with
a check the Knight starts jumping there
could be an F2 issue and it's not like
White's attacking Black's King so let's
see what happened
right now Rook D5 okay we were talking
about C5 well white feels kind of
compelled right you know yes he's
starting to think I've got to use my
majority G5
I told you
Victor korchnoy would tell you that when
you play the move G5 you're making a
very responsible decision yeah
yeah and the first time I suggested the
victor of move like G5 in a position
we're analyzing together he looked at me
and he said yes sir
you do know that pawns don't come back
[Music]
let's play G5 uh okay a very responsible
uh it looks good but like as you said
what's the threat well he wants to take
the Rook right okay so let's after you
you move let's assume I moved the rock
if you move like
being that
let's try it you want to play G4
can I play G4
you want to play Knight takes deep fries
take a pawn
um I
tried Knight E3 and then I feel like
actually I just thinking uh White is not
on time to attack and then
black black Bishop literally black
Square Bishop is so strong well let's
just see so I take a pawn so you're
welcome to kind of walk can I can I play
Chrome B6 was the idea in ID3 yes
absolutely and my intention was to try
to pin well now I can take on D6 though
what's the idea we should okay
I mean we're just throwing the patties
here
you want
you want him don't tell anybody
uh there are some tricky lines it's not
just completely play on one goal
um one of the things that
I don't like the move G5
maybe the engine does and and you make a
move like G5 for for what I would call a
tactical reason sure in your case you
want to buy G5 G4 take apart and I
appreciate that I appreciate that uh but
I tend to think much more strategically
long term like
you know uh what are the ramifications
of G5 so in my in my mind I'm kind of
wanting to play on the dark squares
I would love this bishop to be out and I
would just like say okay go ahead do
your worst or you're going to take or
you're going to play like I don't know
I'm just gonna put some mood right now
like this I don't see any any need to be
aggressive in this position in this
block what while what needs to find
something in themselves right and they
need to create something because their
position is not looking great exactly
and the other thing is I don't
I I I don't think White's Rook is very
good yeah I don't think the bishop is
very good and when your opponent's
pieces aren't well played
let them stay let them stay exactly yes
we have a guest in studio who's going to
explain to us
he made he makes it look easy this
Brandon guy so I'm gonna switch out
perfect
don't be so happy
and we're gonna get branded
yes sir I like having you back yeah yeah
right bye
Brendan congrats on your first win can
you please tell me about the game a
little bit it felt like you had a very
easy win today thank you yeah
so you play this qga against me last
time we played in the fall class about a
year ago so I was trying to find
something interesting um and I think
white play was actually a pretty
unpleasant choice for him practically
like I know the computer says it's
probably totally fine for him but um
yeah it's fine after Knight C4 did you
guys
no so last time against A6 I played I
played B3 instead of their Asics here
here just in there I played them sorry
Bishop B2 I played B3 B3 and then the
main line yeah he played B6 and I went
Bishop A3 and went for this long line I
ended in a drop but um
so yeah and out of the opening I was
actually worse so yeah I tried to find
an improvement um and yeah after Knight
C4 I think like
so I know the best move for him is Queen
C7 yeah
actually yeah so if Queen E7 the point
is now A3
um
then after A5
Knight D4 and Black's in pretty serious
trouble here Knight B3 is coming
so the points with the queen and C7
black has Bishop A6 after Knight D4 so
let's say A3 A5 if Knight D4 Black Goes
Bishop A6 no there's no Knight C6 and
Black's just in time to get his pieces
out kind of so but I mean at the same
time it's pretty counter-intuitive to
put the queen in the C file when I can
go Bishop DT Rook C1 also
so I felt like it was pretty difficult
for black to figure out
um and already after a castle Knight D6
I mean I'm sort of getting what I want
here yeah but yeah here I think you made
a pretty serious mistake of taking md6 I
think he should give the other Bishop
with Queen E7
so I take on C8 or it takes C8
yeah so something like A3
A5 and then B3 which should still be
slightly better but it feels like black
stars for Bishop is much better place
like on D6 let's say than his last three
Bishop would be
um and he can neutralize my Bishop on BT
so it feels like you're put you already
have some pressure right yeah which is a
little bit better but let's say black
plays something like Rook d8 here yeah
um Bishop B2 Knight E5
Queen C2 let's say Knight takes F3
Bishop takes F3 or C8 Queen E2 we get
some position like this black and maybe
go E5 and okay white should be is
slightly better with two Bishops but I
mean Black's still pretty solid here is
no weak no clear weaknesses was that
your prep too for today I mean I
remembered something like this I wasn't
exactly sure if it was this but like I
knew generally the petition afterward
takes C it is like it's a little bit
better for white but Black's still super
solid
um
um yeah I was at a prep but I figured it
kind of felt wrong to keep back with the
light Square Bishop yeah
um I think Ricky one is kind of a smart
move here because I think when he was
counting I was getting some quick
counter play so let's say instead of
Rick D1 I go B3
I already is getting somebody for
counter play I don't really have a good
Square for my queen
um it makes sense probably he he wanted
to right exactly yeah and like after
Rook D1 Bishop D5 like again here if I'm
not accurate let's say I play something
like Knight T4 just kind of careless
then Knight E4
Queen A3 let's say and then Queen H4 and
already Black's getting pretty actively
G3 Queen H3 this is not exactly what I
want okay but I think 95 was a pretty
smart move just immediately neutralizing
all
because like the problem is not coming
quickly with F3 and E4 and there's not
really much
much and yeah I mean it looks like it
kind of just collapsed from here but
already I think it's very difficult for
him to to find a plan yeah I mean
probably giving up the other Bishop
wasn't great I mean it makes sense
because I guess he figures gonna get
shut out with F3 E4 at some point
probably he should just try to take on
E5 and just play 27 and play this
position I mean it's not pleasant I go
F3 but um maybe it's just going with
theater X8 and kind of Justice he
thought he's suffering year two and he
tried to play like looking 27 can be
eight and then somehow like you know get
the pieces out yeah I think he was
trying to like exchange light Square
Bishop too so that doesn't get trapped
and he might have some tricks with the
Knights but yeah I don't think it really
worked out for him perfect
um so Brandon you started the tournament
well yeah these white faces
um how are you feeling so far no it
feels good it feels good I just I just
finished the junior clothes not too long
ago so just been hanging out in St Louis
so it felt nice to sort of refresh and
take a step back and just sort of relax
before this ornament and like I think
for me it's pretty nice because I'm sort
of warmed up from the last tournament
but I saw enough rest where I don't feel
like burned out or anything so it's
great to start with the wind I'm ready
to fight okay perfect I'm glad to hear
that
let's watch the next game which is
Benjamin work book and Nichols Theodore
I hate those 100 accuracy
this position looks slightly better for
white I would say
yeah it does but
if black trades the poems with D5 I mean
it's like uh you got nothing I know
but they're trying to do that
can I play like Rook demon Rook D4 and
just yes
so I do get Rook D1 and
Rook that would be fine I know my black
should hold it even without the pawn
because you're gonna like exchange a
night to Bishop and everything right but
still like it's like suffering for a
long time right is it suffering though
so let's just go
it is suffering
like some mgms think oh you just give
away the pawn and then you have this
like you know setup right
so like the first thing is if I play
King E7 yeah
is if you play Rook D4 Rook check is
annoying that is true so whatever you're
going to do you have to include Bishop
F3 so that you can go King G2 and then
you you can go but I black can also like
activate their pieces Rook A1 A2 and
Rook c8c to basically just give away the
point that's right that's exactly right
yeah uh if I just as you described it if
I wanted to go in for a variation like
this you know
uh I would like to not to save the
bishop though no to lose the bishop you
you'd want to draw back with a rook
no uh that is true yeah
yeah so if you drop back with the or or
King James okay so then this this is
what why I wanted to put my king here
begin with my idea is that if you give
me a check I'm just gonna go here you're
gonna be like comfy I'm just gonna like
hang out and what I'm going to really do
to be super super annoying
[Laughter]
all right but let's uh let's just go
around the horn here a bit
um Ilya did you already look at that
that was the first result of the game
yes let's look at that from the
beginning though it's a Queen's Gambit
I think they are they are from our
teammates right Elia graduated Webster
as well exactly
[Music]
and this is why
what's goes back
to the 2000s and a game of Vladimir
kramnik
and even the the the
um
moves look a little peculiar Bishop a
A5 and the little switch and zoom in
between move 94. these are all vetted
and tested theoretical uh moves like the
players are just so incredibly well
prepared like black said okay do your
worst do your worst do your worst do
your worse and he ends up in a position
in such positions if you equalize your
clothes immediately you gotta know
otherwise it's just worse for black
usually exactly uh equalized
we're very very very much so uh has
black already
fate also just like one of those
when uh my view on chess
in the sense that when you trade Queens
yeah so a queen trade when should we
trade Queens it's a very important
consequent decision you take the Queens
off the board you're taking the most
powerful Pieces away right you lose
you're reducing the attacking chances
so whenever my king is more vulnerable
than yours let's trade that's Queens
when you have when I have an attacking
position and your King's more vulnerable
than mine I'm looking to trade Queens
second thing is
when we trade Queens think of yourself
as being at a marketplace where you know
you got bread I got the cheese you got
the eggs and so on
so the idea is I want to trade on my
terms so black could take the queen here
but that's trading on White's terms and
after Knight takes suddenly you've got
to deal with this threat and maybe you
gotta yeah and the next thing you know
you're on the back foot you know like
and the Knight B7 is coming yes sir
anyways it might be well at the moment
the bishop right or no I understand and
you've got uh well B2 is hanging uh too
but like
that's
it's like I wanna one of those
variations whoops
but no question about it that Knight B7
is it's very dangerous yes absolutely
but what black says is yeah let's trade
Queens but let's trade in on my terms I
don't want to see your night landing on
D6 but if the knight's gonna land on D6
my King's gonna be on E7 and let's go so
I I really like that last little uh
sequence that we just I really like how
you explain that too yeah thank you uh
trade trade and now boy I don't think
the position could get any more dry than
it has
and
the players
there's this uh there was this book now
I forgot uh what title it's from it's
Schwartz
versus Vice
and they ended up literally getting into
a position that was identical really
yeah yeah white and black and I mean
imagine the pawn is on A6 the pawn is on
H3 and it's like draw agreed so what
happens if you cannot offer a draw
they find this which is called a
repetition I don't think he played King
E4 by the way I think that was just the
the king getting placed on the squid yes
on the Square it's like one of those
things where you might end up fighting
right like they did like what what yeah
okay that was a draw and let's see where
would you like to go if you found some
games that caught your attention yeah
let's go to the Beagle
uh uh well first of all let's go to our
Marquee match up that is also true
and when we left it we left it here
about this time
think I was just recommending take
takes takes
give the opponent the
superior minor piece I have a feeling
Christian he just wants to keep the
pieces and play he's a very fighting
player oh for sure so
Darius was like never mind I'm just
gonna take it okay uh something very
important just happened by the way which
was the trait of the minor pieces uh the
bishop for the night but the trade had a
consequence begin the the the pawn got
on light Square black has the light
Square bishop and as we know
in those types of resulting positions
the bishop isn't as effective yes it was
a good trade and I love how he played H4
and then he's like basically
getting yeah getting the ponds close
closer to opponents inside you know what
I mean and then actually night is way
better than the bishop Bishop doesn't
have any squares and like to attack or
be useful basically in this position so
the knight in country certain sense uh
controls and dominates uh the bishop and
then from the Japanese game of Go they
have been worked to suji to suji is to
dominate so in this case the Knight
dominates the bishop but it's very
interesting how when this two squares
like imagine the bishop goes here yeah
on F5
then the bishop dominates the Knight
in the sense the Knight would like to go
to aggressive squares right but the
bishop
dominates yeah E4 D4 and so on uh
actually that's that's the reason why he
played H4 too right so that he could
maybe play G4 or H5
so tsuji uh between the Knight and the
bishop yeah is when there's two squares
in between them so for example the worst
case would be you have to imagine that
this white knight was on the A1 Square
oh that's terrible then this bishop is
on the A4 Square
so the name is completely powerless
can't move anywhere I love like you know
there are moments when you flip Blitz or
wrap it and then you just like see the
move and the Knight cannot move Knight
cannot move so in this position I'm
I'm fairly comfortable
comfort for yeah but what I really want
desperately to do
is I desperately want to Target this
point yeah I want to put the Knight on
F4 and go after D5 with all guns blazing
the problem is
the way I see it at least let me explain
it like that is that the desirable
movement at Knight D3 gets hit by Bishop
A6 Knight C and then The Bishop's great
and G5 is coming too G5 is coming and
the bishop
protects the weakness and in some ways
it's that tesuji I was saying it kind of
dominates also I don't like F6 by black
it just creates forever not specific
Square for the night yeah you can
control the E5 square but whenever
Knight comes to E5 you can play F6 right
it usually is like that after F6 when
they can like move the Knight and Rook
C7 and slowly like that fortnite E6
there's so other instance like E6 square
and G7 points right so the idea is that
you play the move F6 if I ever get a
rook on the seventh rank it's more
effective
the rank a little bit it's a huge
decision to play F6 in general
indeed indeed it is it's
as you said Christian I told you yeah
don't move backwards exactly uh the
reason why I don't H4 is fine I'm not a
particularly big fan because what I'm
saying is my goal Foster yeah I want to
have the Knight on F4 and I want to have
the Rook on C5 but I run into Bishop A6
ah so I mean being the clever person I
am
I would play the move Rook here first
now go ahead and tell me what you would
like to do for black if you ever go I
like to play this position okay so what
no rookie seven let's just play like G5
okay excellent so I won't give you
Knight F4 okay so the Knight is not
jumping so now I'll play Rook too no I'm
forced to protect did it can I play
Asics I'm curious I know it's such an
awful move but okay tactically it will
work right so this is where I'm uh
heading is for me the ultimate goal is
going after they're still going
afterwards but still if you take on D5
life and my Bishop on E6 I'm not sure if
we can trade on like you know trade your
A5 Rook to my B8 rook and then maybe
bishop will be enough to protect the
position like and then hitting on A2
Palm okay so after Rook A5 your turn
king of seven so A3
so what I'm doing with the move A3 is
I'm taking a Pawn on the light Square
moving it to a dark Square meaning that
later my Pawn is not going to be
vulnerable and what I'm really trying to
do is is to prep a protected Square yeah
that's exactly what I'm trying to do
you're not taking my I'm offering a Pawn
on A6 I was afraid of Rook A8
no the Europe
um
[Music]
but this is this is the type one more
move for you go ahead what would you do
it's just hard to fly like
right yeah so like for example maybe I
should should play Bishop F5 actually
instead of H5 and give me the A6 yeah
just take it so I can actually activate
my pieces you're a very nice person they
told me that you would not give me any
material any I know you loved any balls
I do I do it's just about root B2 and
rupee 7 is coming right and by the way
what you said about the seventh rank
really here we go
it's not fun anyway the point there
that
that we think darush is for choice and
um and Sassy has got to by the way look
at this move from before yeah exactly
kind of being in it kind of like a in
your face and maybe on a very good day
you get to play Rook C4 and try to
create another game session won't watch
this exactly what the heck they're doing
what were they worried about H4 okay but
once again I think
a move like Rook C3 Rook B3 you see I
look at this position
and I I always ask myself what are your
good pieces and what are my good pieces
and if I go back to just this position I
would say that the good pieces that
black has are the Rooks
and like this Rook yeah it's kind of
blocked this one well it's kind of
playing a defensive role right more like
that so when I see the move Rook B4 one
of the things I start thinking is how
can I get that Rook out of my business I
want to get rid of this rook and the
fact of the matter is that this Rook is
more active than this Rook so I look at
it and I say I'm trying to try to get
rid of my passive piece for your active
piece we'll keep an eye on this one
let's go to and then we have a result oh
do we already B section in the B section
okay that's this group jump over there I
do believe Alshon and
basoren made a draw
again that occurred fast and this is a
catalyt
are you a Cattleman player by the way I
do play with black and then oh against
the Cadillac I I do play with why too
okay uh it just depends if I know the
line I like it if I don't know it I
don't like it so for example uh here
we're at a very important Crossroads for
the entirety of the Catalan complex
there are two two ways of playing you
can capture the pawn
and that's where we have what we call
the open Catalan
or you maintain the pawn
D5 you you lock in this bishop and we
have the closed Catalan so for example
if I play the open Catalan you might say
oh in that case I'll play the Catalan
against you because so do you like when
you're playing the Catalan as why do you
like it when they play the open or the
closed
you like to play against uh I would say
open open yeah so that's much more close
is like kind of easier to put the pieces
for a while they just now like you play
B3 Bishop F4 and then just go to Korean
Knight C3 so I was like lower rated
players I would like
but
I was higher rated players probably open
one okay uh C7 C6 didn't your coach ever
say don't look at the rating big of just
just play the best move in the position
at all time yeah everyone says
you look at the rating I get it uh C7 C6
so there it is there
uh closed Catalan in all of its Glory
Rook C1 a7a5 so one of the things about
the closed is oftentimes these Queen
side pieces
yeah trust me I played it was black and
then it's just pure suffering I would
say you just try to do something with
the C8 bishop and then it by just
pressing all the time right okay so one
of the things I would love to do if I
was black is I'd just love to trade
Rooks I like oh that would be great
on the board yeah say to my opponent
would you like the train just begin take
that off can we please and my opponent
agrees I'm happy right because then I
don't even have to worry about my bishop
move absolutely so the idea being what's
the idea behind A5 the idea behind A5 is
very simple
I want to play the move A4 and then what
I want to do is I want to get in a
position like this
where I cannot play B3 right right
but let's suppose you could have played
B3 like instead of playing King H2 just
for argument's sake we would have played
the move Bishop C3
now I understand I'm losing the pawn but
this is the whole idea of Black's play
of A5 A4 is he's open up the Rook Trade
It Off The Rook so he talked to his
opponent and he said let's get rid of
The Rook so the idea behind a5a4 is at
some moment you think that white might
play the move B3 great let's trade Rooks
and if for example you do play the move
B3 and I play a for in principle
you know I know I shouldn't take such
pawns but even in my last tournament
recently I still took it I'm like
dynamically it sounds good okay uh and
this is just horrible right
I lost the game oh
uh A5 let's see what happened actually
let me just uh refresh my board
apologies because I've got some analysis
in there that kind of messed he did play
B3 bike week yeah yeah okay B5 now that
uh move I'm not
a fan I don't like this move at all
and I think after the most principle
move
that's what I was thinking after C5
what's your idea you can play B4 than A3
correct in fact Black's idea is to leave
the pawns and not and not commit them so
after A4 is ideas to play B4 and after
B4 his ideas to play A4 and then it's a
big fight over E5 and E4 normally
speaking you can't get an E5 I'm going
to play Bishop F4 so normally speaking
what black tries to do is fight over
control of E4 but I like the cramped
um suffering yeah this this Pawn is
actually pretty useful probably his idea
was to play Knight E4 F5 Knight df6
Bishop design Bishop E8 Bishop H5
basically that's the idea you were way
too fast where what was his idea if
after C5 probably black wanted to play
Knight E4 Knight E4 yeah yes 92305 F5
his idea E8
with the idea at night yeah here here
here here that's the ideal position as
in a as in a stone wall yeah you just
get uh I have the stone wall the actual
position repertoire yes did you did you
play the status I did play with black
it's it's just bad don't play
first folks whenever you see those books
it says winning with the stone wall you
can do it you can beat your opponents
play The Dutch stone wall
never mind he did not do that he did not
do that he after B5 he said look
I'm I'm I'm kind of happy let me go here
but here's the problem
this bishop on CA which was kind of this
passive locked in Bishop is actually now
doing really good and you've got to jump
to B5
and if you look at the position is great
right right I would play for one year it
was black I'm like okay getting ready
exactly and because again I'm starting
to look around like I said like I tell
you I look around and I say are you
happy yeah
your phone is gorgeous yeah I've got two
unhappy guys
I kind of think this guy's a little uh
put the bishop on F4 and he would be
saying you know like I'm proud of myself
looking across the board I see a lot of
happy people
yeah I probably like dynamically we're
not on time though well let's see
because uh the game did let's just
remind everybody the game did end in a
draw but oh
that is a strange model
uh uh I agree that's very strange I mean
night is great before Pawn is great on
like so the immediate question is
probably it's not good but I just have
to
quickly take a look if I did
Bishop F1 I was so insulting as to
aim to grab a queen A4 Rooks Queen A4 is
a nice Tempo isn't it
and I had I had to please learn too
active here
it feels like it right yeah like
Bishop A6 probably getting the pond back
although if that gets upon back then I
really am unhappy
um
can I play text no never mind
but
yeah it
I have some activity yeah but like
nothing for sure right yeah it's not uh
it it doesn't feel like a problem it
should be five probably okay six uh of
playing for a win yeah I don't think
like black is doing better here I
wouldn't be sure but tonight
yeah it again it just kind of doesn't
feel like I'm playing for a week but
might do six
then vocation
and then probably Queen A1 saves after
like Queen C8 Queen a queen E5 couldn't
see one queen queen C8 Queen
sorry Queen A5
Quincy one just you can't even drop back
Queen A1 so Knight G5 nothing is like G5
925 is not an idea anymore right right
it didn't happen let's just jump to what
did happen after Bishop E1 he didn't he
dropped back with the Knight
Queen B2 H6 Bishop F1 and somehow
white just managed to
yeah Black's idea was to trade one pair
of knights and then put the other pair
but it's it's taking so much time and
taking away the pressure that
yeah
this in the old Soviet Union
they had these uh
uh chess writers that spoke of the open
file the openc file and they called it
The Chopping Block that was where you
just traded the pressure and the trade
and the trades all happened yeah on the
C file but at some point we figured that
if the files openc file we can put so
much pressure through that too yeah and
that's where we saw the roots come off
yeah
game for white and it kind of Elston had
an easy easy day easy day with the black
pieces uh Luca one of the locals here
he's my teammates okay
wonderful and from Serbia they're going
to yeah this is
wow look at this I remember
when I was playing the French defenses
black and we would get to a position
like this and that would be enough we
would like say okay that's our
preparation no no not today nowadays no
it's just the beginning of the prep and
this is all prep I promise you I mean
the moves look straight and also look at
himself plays E6 was black so I'm pretty
confident she knew the line exactly uh
here
there's a question though you see the
move Queen d8 and I'm often times in
this line
there are reasons
long-term long-term reasons why you want
to provoke the move G2 G3 okay so I've
often seen players play the check
provoke the move G3 and then they drop
back in with the queen maybe I can play
Queen H49 19 E2 maybe that's going to be
the problem so I am on time like I have
one more Tempo to play Rook HP one you
know and then the idea is to start maybe
on this album King E2 yes
I'm developing my peers what do you want
okay thank you you too that's a that's a
funny way of thinking about it
developing your king everybody think
about how today
okay it's not the best but they're
saying uh many times I think sorry the
the other important thing is that B5
Bishop B5 and Knight B5 are a problem
and after King E2 actually I cannot
right this this might be
embarrassing I just think like that you
know okay logic is important
uh chat no check
yeah
no testing of the check look at this
bishop B6
oh the check
Lucas
look at windows can
nice okay Queen to G4
the the that's
wow wow well well one of the benefits I
want to say uh vegan one of the nice
benefits that white enjoys having made
this uh move Bishop B6 is he doesn't
have to deal with B5 okay so that's cool
that's the but wow check this move out
Knight E4 so essentially what white is
saying
is that you are so tied up
that I even have time
no but you cannot do it also can you I
can that looks like it's that looks like
it's
done and dusted rookies
no I I still I still just you still take
take Queen before and that castle Yeah
done done invested so you the night is
untouchable
it should be E7 black has
you know you I think anybody who's ever
played chess for any length of time has
always had those one games where it's
like all I need is one move like if I
can Castle you know if black castles
he's upon up
he's ready to take he's ready to take
he's like oh just one tempo does it
and we have a result Justin wearing a
loss against aksha Chandra
wow that happened fast too uh we'll get
there we just saw the move Knight C5
Bishop C5 Bishop
finally
wow
threatening Queen before what a great
preparation isn't it it's amazing
F6 making room for the king
and then also uh
yeah yeah you can see Luca didn't spend
any time no not one hour 34 minutes and
it's all preparation preparation oh my
gosh look at this
takes takes H3 Queen F5 oh my gosh what
a preparation
rookie
rookie four and as we go through this
amazing preparation I'm gonna just pause
myself and say we have a guest in studio
this time you're out the door
[Laughter]
you'll be missed
greatly
uh
and we'll just finish up here
my gosh what a preparation
what a preparation
long time no see right wow nice
yes perfect yes perfect indeed just
looking at
actually oh first of all big welcome big
uh congratulations we're just finishing
up this game of uh Luca and Simeon and
with just amazing preparation these guys
what they what they
work on yeah yeah for sure now this line
is very topical I think Fabi played it
against Ellie Reza as well right
recently either you remember everything
or you just lose on the spot pretty much
I was about to say it looks like black
has weathered the storm his King went
out to G6 but somehow the Queens got
traded and whites empty-handed here uh
too many pawns let's get to your game
first of all you're playing Justin Wang
who just finished the
um
us junior Championship so I guess
you looked at those games uh I took a
quick look but there wasn't anything
which could really help me none of his
opponents played the openings I played
so disturbing what happened tell us uh
first of all you're black and you chose
open Sicilian yeah so I was surprised by
Bishop E2 and move nine
I mean I vaguely remember some some idea
with F4 what do you play but I had no
idea what I'm supposed to do usually
they just they just go Queen D2 and
either cast along or play for Knight D5
it looks looks smart Queen D2 castle
Yeah
and then away you go pretty much and you
were ready for that yeah that's what I
was expecting as opposed to the side
variation Bishop yeah Bishop 2 is
probably super rare I I don't even know
if like there are that many games but
isn't there a logic glitch here for
white though first of all you've played
F3 F4 well that's modern chess none of
the principles matter anymore you can
play F3 F4 and it's still better for
white he's he's induced you to play H
Yeah by threatening to play G4 right
yeah I thought his idea was to follow
with H3 then and then castle like Castle
short like H3 immediately well F4 first
and let's say I played Queen C7 and now
H3 okay
I was wondering during the game how am I
going to Castle
because Bishop E7 Castle I mean maybe I
could sack a pawn but it's kind of
uncomfortable yeah
yeah the pon's always a problem right
any I mean I probably would play
something with H4 but again if I castle
that probably could be a bit loose okay
and these thoughts are going through
your mind like how am I gonna right yeah
F4 Queen C7 castles tell me when things
started going in your opinion in your
favor
I have no idea I like I couldn't
evaluate anything for most of the game I
was surprised by Queen D2 though I
thought he would take on G4 for sure
right I mean I don't even know if Knight
G4 is good it seems kind of dubious but
maybe it's all right I was going to take
with a pawn okay and I was calculating
F5 okay Bishop C4 okay rookie one
Knight F6
and I thought maybe I have ideas with
like long castle and G5 here for example
Bishop G5
I thought I could go long Castle here
okay and it seemed pretty interesting
there's like one funny line I calculated
uh you're gonna meet me on the H file
yeah so Bishop F6 gf6 Knight D5
oh Knight D5 yeah Bishop takes D5 Queen
takes D5 yeah Queen B6 check if you goes
to F1 I take on H2 King H1 G3
no I played G3 first oh sorry yeah it's
coming yes yes yes so yes this is the
the this everybody should have hardwired
right yeah
because it's such a nice uh too yeah and
then you have the double thread of mate
but also this makes yeah that's right so
King F1 and Rook H2 yeah
so I mean there's no way he would go for
this it was just a funny line I saw
during the game yeah right
okay nice uh he gave up his dark Square
bishop and yeah I thought it should be
okay after that but still it wasn't so
easy over the board yeah it should be
795. I spent a lot of time here because
I wasn't sure if I should allow the FTX
E5 structure I should take on F4 first
like so if I Castle he's gonna go f
takes E5 and D6
so that's a nasty idea I don't know if I
can hold here but it looks really scary
gf6 and like uh he could he could always
play Queen G3 Queen H6
he has at least to draw it looks this is
not he's not what we played chess for
you know like suffering no no so I
thought maybe I play Rook d8 first
anticipating f65 and D6 right but then
on a C4
wasn't really sure what's going on here
it's unclear it feels like I kind of
have to take it on F4 at some point
which is why it in the game you did
yeah I was just worried if the Night
Comes to F5 like Knight d495 but he's
not in time I always said Knight takes
D5 here right and has happened in the
game C4 Kea somehow we can't quite
coordinate his pieces so I mean yeah
you're you're fearing that the magic
move Knight D4 and fight happens and one
go right yeah and then you get to go
Queen G3 as well and then you're
suffering yeah so you have to avoid that
setup and uh Rook aea
well okay he in anticipation of yeah
this movie surprised me also I thought
he would go Queen H3 I thought that was
his point that's what I spent all my
time thinking about when I played he
takes F4 yeah I thought he'd go Queen H3
oh pardon me excuse me yeah to hit the
pawn on H5 makes sense
I still wasn't entirely sure what I was
gonna play
because now he's like he also wants to
double up on the f file makes sense as
well
maybe I would sack the poem with Bishop
d8 as in the game yeah yeah just to say
big deal you get you get something right
yeah I have some good play on the dark
squares I don't think I should be worse
here I don't either uh in the game and
sorry that I have to speed you up
because yeah no worries uh we reached
this point now tell us how you got to G5
in your mind like what was it so I was
thinking perfect timing to actually
you're gonna love this I'm sitting here
telling the fact that to begum I like
Black's position I like Black's position
a lot in that The Rook on F4 and the
bishop on F3 aren't really scaring
anybody then you play G5
okay next game
so how did you come up with G5 well I
was considering one of the previous one
instead of rookie five but it doesn't
quite work he has worked at five and aha
I can't really catch them so the
immediate G5 he's got Rook F5 and yeah
okay so you played rookie rookie five
yeah centralized The Rook repairs to
double up and also covers the F5 Square
okay so your thinking was that this Rook
even though it might look stupid doesn't
have a really good Square along the
fourth ring yeah because if he moves it
laterally I get g494 and
looks very scary Bishop G5 is coming
he's got a bunch of
threats he has to deal with to his King
gotcha I figured he would go for some
version of The Exchange SEC what he did
in the game okay this just looks
absolutely terrifying okay Queen G3 Rook
F6 so you essentially induced him to
sacrifice but you've got active pieces
this is actually yeah he has some
compensation but like my pieces work
together so well he just can't never get
his Knight to a good square and the pawn
Pawn's kind of loose as well
actually this feels like a really nice
game like you can hear these days for me
yeah I know I mean this is this is this
is a dream like you know you you don't
even think about going on this diagonal
yeah and in the meantime the DC Pawn is
not really a runner
yeah it's kind of sad for him that he
can't do anything like I don't even Rush
would see before I go Bishop B6 first
and that potential idea of C4 just
lethal exactly exactly yeah I like wow
feels really
yeah here I was just not sure if I
should take on C4 rookie one maybe you
can tell me what's the more precise move
Queen takes C4 rookie one you know I
once had this debate with Jan Timon not
about this particular position any move
action
that induces resignation I guess I
should you don't have to double guess
yourself
congratulations thank you appreciate it
nice nice nice uh coming in what's your
ambitions uh no Ambitions really
so a good chance it's a good start yeah
all right thank you so much yeah yeah
thank you absolutely good to see you
yeah thank you for sure oh my gosh wow
all right as I uh run over to another of
the game that's ongoing this one is
between Armada and Andrew
okay this looks like it's going to be
heading for a draw this last move Bishop
F1 it's gonna
capture that guy Luca it's a great
preparation did not pan out Luca is
definitely losing and let me just jump
to the other group
uh darush
versus Krishna four verses 4 looks like
a kind of a drug
we lost you welcome back
very nice you had a very fun interview I
know
I have known act shot for the better
part I'm gonna say of 10 years his
family has moved to the St Louis area
he went slow he's uh he really his chest
uh blossomed let's put it that way being
in the St Louis area because uh when you
think about the club all of the
activities and he's just rubbing
shoulders with all the grand Masters in
the area something's going to you know
rub off
so and also we talked about this game
earlier yeah exactly it doesn't work out
and uh I'm just looking at darrish and
sassy and that game is heading for a
draw by the way in this a group two
draws this will be the third one let's
jump to the game of our newly minted
Mishra as he this looks like a French
defense yes indeed it is we're just
going to go very very quickly from
previous play to current position
and I want to say though
very very often
it's difficult
to play quiet positions positions where
the the the or the all of the game and
uh decision they and Daria schwarzen
yeah was wrong uh you're you you're
under some pressure and you have this
strong desire to lash out G5 is a very
very bad no no I don't like this move at
all it feels like a big money you wanted
to get some Dynamic play here yeah but
it also is kind of an indication that
well
um he's fearful of being pressured in
this position
if you don't play G5 bacon if you had to
play another move what move would you
play I was playing
very good King C7 King B7 because what
that move does is it gets a bad piece
the King on D7 out of the way and onto a
better Square B7 you vacate the D7
Square
but I have another view my view is that
my bad piece is not my king the king the
center is closed you're not attacking my
my my king any checks will easily be met
by Knight C6 my bad piece is the queen
ID I agree on that
like a queen G8
wingy
you want a blue Queen H7 and then Queen
E4 or Knight F5 uh
my queen is much much better placed on
G8
I'm also thinking about those dynamics
of what you said of G5 and F6 kind of
play but then again my queen would be
better positioned in that case please I
have a feeling Misha was kind of
oh no he just lost the game yes
look at three Rook f8
what what Mishra did with the move G5
is he turned his King side into a porous
Target and somehow King end up
protecting E6
not good H6 Pawn is under attack he
didn't want to play H5 basically the
dark squares and then Knight comes to G5
you play G5
but look at this now the porous one of
your best moves right now well it's one
of the best movies
right if you could play G5 G7 the Knight
is coming to G4 and here we go
uh yeah so if you could combine your
idea and my idea wow that would be
perfect yeah maybe you should play
tournaments together right one move you
to make a second if these teams and
competitions oh I played twice in China
with mixed team competition I must say
though I had an incredibly good partner
which
won the competition uh zushan she was
the Women's World Champion yeah I know
former world champion and uh I know
she's a strong player
uh well Mishra lost a pawn and look at
this it just it's just a home run he's
he's suffering I have a feeling
abhimanyu lost to this game by choice
unfortunately
wow and for pranav a very very
nice he he defeated a very good opponent
by the way Mishra went through the U.S
junior Championship completely
unblemished I do believe he was the only
player uh in the U.S Juniors not to lose
a single game and uh but very
very one-sided game here today and I do
believe
that the culprit for his demise
he wrote this
is if I want a G5 this move absolutely
this is when you you lash out because
you're afraid of this or that but if you
hit play if he pardon me not you but if
he had played the move Queen G8 with the
idea of Queen H7 you're kind of
eyeballing like if white for example
often times in these positions white
often times thinks that his King
it's right so he does this kind of thing
and let's Echo night peace or you know I
like your idea to go King here if white
goes Queen F3 not saying that this is a
good move or not one of the benefits
yeah of having the queen on H7 I think
Queen G8 Queen H7 is a great idea and
then you're protecting your weaknesses
and bringing all out your pieces for
stem preparing
well I hope we'll get uh uh pranoff to
join us and share his uh
thoughts about that it's nice nice
Victory today and just jumping to a game
between ronic I hope I'm pronouncing his
name correctly versus John Burke
um Queen ending one two two yeah sir do
you need any help yes how many fingers
that's five versus four I like the the
player with the five
absolutely I like the player pawns are
important but the tricky part is that uh
so dirty no no it's white to move when
they can play Queen G3 that's tricky
okay but then but they're not saving the
pawns King it's absolutely yeah well I'm
gonna get a queen Kingdom game no I can
take uh where's the king I'm getting
no matter what I do yeah that is true
right if you take with a pawn I got
I go up on Angie if you take with the
queen
I've got a king
it's just like uh but this is the
question is it it's better for black
because he's going to have the more
active King but the D5 one is falling
down
so then it's just a win it's just a win
but if I don't uh get the pawn then I'm
Pawn down and then you're threatening to
play actual Queen A1 Queen A4 as well
okay but here's the thing can I get some
counter play Maybe with this guy so
let's say I take take I'm not happy
don't don't get me wrong I'm not happy
right
decide I mean I'm taking on D5 as well
if if you take on D5 this is the counter
play that I was talking
but Queen H4 H4 H3
or h4h3 that that's that's an issue but
like Queen G1 we shouldn't forget about
Queen G1 right yeah then I'm not on time
that's embarrassing
but yeah that's the counter play you you
yeah absolutely you rip away the counter
plate and so it might be that this is
just a winning position for John as this
move and by the way he played F4 F3
which is a very strong move yeah he
really immediately yeah he realized that
look you know I've got
that King and pawn end game
that we've been talking about and I've
got this queen ending which should be
winning let's just jump
control tab
wow we only have one thanks when Luca
what happened to his position he was
deep into his preparation yes he must be
boomeranged the preparation excuse me
can we go back a little bit sure we're
gonna have to go out back a way big bit
after Queen E7 we love this game but
right and we thought okay this is what
went wrong right H3 Queen rookie three
three
and he had nine and like his opponent
had nine minutes and he had 43 minutes
Luca and with this move queen says I got
a feeling that he went this far in his
preparation because he's he's
threatening GT which is winning
but after E5 maybe thinking of castles
was wrong Maybe
oh maybe it said maybe it was overcraft
one
rockef
you're blowing my mind
what's the difference that maybe Queen
H3 something is not with check
remind me asking
asking uh I guess you've got to take the
bishop why else did you play B5
that yes exactly that was my thinking
was just but after Queen G5 threatened
me anything now nothing absolutely
Inglorious but it feels weird the
position already feels weird no question
it's weird the King on G6
um I I have a feeling castles as you
said castles doesn't look right
something's off with that move takes
takes
now here I mean let's let's we could we
could go check but this our King is
gonna you know like if we go Queen C6
Jack and we we greedily
we greedily grabbed the pawn well we
just got the result look uh resigned
yeah
uh he did even you know one of the worst
things
you know we talk about bad things that
can happen in chess yes okay we all
understand that the worst thing that can
happen in chess is that we lose a game
that's bad it's not the worst thing that
can happen any game you want to know the
absolutely absolutely worst thing that
can happen in game as you lose that's
bad
but you lose a game where you show all
your great preparation so the whole
world now knows what you've been working
on and then you still listening
trust me I have so many like
it's a weird thing because women will
never regret about it as like men do I
have so many uh like guys friends and
then after the game I'm like oh I'm
sorry you lose the game they're like no
it's fine but I'm mad that I showed my
preparation and I did exactly as you
said I I'm like why for me it's
different if I lose the game I lose the
game regardless of whether it was well
prepared or otherwise exactly and but
for me it's so important to have the
preparation and not lose the game oh for
sure because again you know you work
really really hard on a chess trust me
when I say that these players coming to
the game they prepare they put hours of
of Blood Sweat and Tears they get their
preparation on the board and then they
lose the game then it's like now all the
opponents say ah so that's what you've
been studying that's what you're working
on and no I'm going to study it as well
and you get this big fat zero so that
was uh that is upsetting that's always
upsetting that's very very tough and it
I mean either this is Perfect Defense
and uh semian was incredibly well
prepared or just around these parts
um the prep something something went
awry with the prep maybe it's the little
Queen C7 I'm not even sure why I need to
move Queen to Queens do you want to
believe g4nister
for example G4
looks interesting but I was more Queen
D6 like yeah just
okay now I understand C7 so the idea is
you want to play yeah and then protect
uh
I have a feeling here after E5 uh by the
way this also Dodges rookie
after E5 like it it should be good for a
ride
it should be good for white I agree or
maybe uh lemon also was trying to recall
his line basically it's also possible
that maybe it's if you're both sides are
precise it's just you know as usual it's
equal
um well Castle is really
doesn't look right and indeed let's say
a pipe Bishop B3
just for example if you take there is a
check so it takes takes check it like
you're you're gonna go back right yeah
Knight F6 so I've uh sorry I don't get
to play 24 is the track indeed Queenie
scores and
okay sorry just got thrown up anyway
that
completes that tournament that's it all
those five games and we have babies
two two draws and group a has so far
three draws
okay and we have the last game of the
day going which is John Bergen ronak and
only in the a group only pranav has won
against Mishra thus far because we think
John Burke as we see on our screens
there former U.S junior Champion uh deny
I mean he played in a U.S junior
Championship
so strong it was that scary good I
remember yeah and uh it was 2021 right
yeah it wasn't it was my first time
playing
really yeah how did you do by the way I
got second which is a fairy
no it was the first time out of the box
well good for you
um but yeah John won a very very nice uh
Championship now he's trying to get into
[Music]
so I have a feeling he's slowly coming
back again to just exactly it feels like
it well one of the things of course when
you were a student in
College it takes so much of your time
that you you don't have the energy to
play in these events and so uh
I know from my own experience it's like
extremely tough and then having two jobs
yeah precisely so here uh just as uh as
as we're up to date with the position no
I don't think we are let me just uh let
me just flash back and forth uh we've
got more money more moves so G4 check
please let's go into that King and pawn
and gang we know it's a win for black
too I would say it's a clever move but
your idea well not
are you in the square no
not all
not even close if we were we were really
really close on this one yeah
nobody's gonna fall for that one but
like I feel like Queen is very passive
on myth too and it is I really don't
want to do anything it is let me just
again I'll uh the queen F2 sets that
incredibly nasty trap so the first thing
is we look at checks right is that what
so for me
there was this terrible book Terrible
book it ruined uh lots of players think
like a grand master oh I know that book
too
it's a terrible terrible book but there
you know
in a pile of manure you're gonna find
something yeah
one of the yeah one of the ideas of the
book was also like you know looking at
candidates moves which is very very good
and the first moves you always look at
are checks and the second moves you
always look at captures you know you so
you look at checks first or other checks
is it good is it bad well we'll find out
and then captures well what should we
should we capture thank you okay so in
this position uh you know the first move
we looked at was actually a capture and
we got it backwards the first move we
should have been looking at is a check
okay actually now I'm kind of like I'm
warming
yeah I think it's clever because is it
you know what's the um
when you check on A1 and try to get any
A4 T5 yeah I'm taking on B6 with a check
ah okay so let's let's take a look so we
go check now clearly
out of we that that's out of business uh
check now I think G3 is out of business
for similar reasons anytime I go forward
ending it's wins the king opponent games
all win so you're pretty much obliged to
retreat and as you were saying or before
I interrupted you any captures if I go
either capturing here or capturing there
or there you're saying Queen takes B6
check and maybe I've got some some some
action uh to look at
I can't take on D5 I can take on G2 and
D5 right so not now sorry yeah okay I
need to be a little bit about it clever
let's see how clever can you be it's
hard to be clever when the
check
maybe I just need to take on G2 but
queen of
you take on
yeah
because we're struggling bacon
it
is a good indication why John 2 is
saying okay just a second uh if the
checks if the captures are bad and if
the checks are bad
um he might be thinking okay I have a
different what what what's a different
approach that I can take
um
I know it's stupid of course but I just
bear me out so if I played a move like
Queen here
takes and if this was yeah so you can be
please
we're talking if you wanna
clever Queen G7
so I'm threatening Queen G2 wins but
it's still check but
or E6 or F6 I like B6 though yeah and
it's like just E6 well then I have to
agree
ah Queen E3 so your your initial uh my
idea was to play King H7 and try to get
how about I can take on G10 and I'm
threatening Queen
yeah that Queen A1 is really really oh
my gosh disturbing but hold on
yes
are you in the Square I can't believe it
no I'm not so one of the things that we
did is we we did it like this we
mentally we draw we draw a square and
say
this is what the pawn and the black king
in this moment needs to play the move
King d8
so
and In This Moment the oops sorry
because we draw this the square needs to
step into C8 yeah unfortunately she's
grabbing the draw here too so how about
not Queen G7 but so G5 then
okay so we're kind of let me just uh
apologize
yeah yeah no no it was Queen F2 so but
this is the moment that John is really
taking a lot of is taking a deep breath
thinking about the position and here
where
struggling with these ideas of check
and check because it ends up at the end
of the day Queen takes b685 you know
like
that's disturbing right like how dare
you searching for
foreign
[Music]
games uh are all winning so how about I
take GTX F3
okay take on F3 gf3
so then I will just
check
this doesn't feel completely
[Laughter]
you're trying to trigger into that I
yeah it's
okay I don't know well here it's the
same thing so I actually have to
it's a little bit better for white
pardon me for black it's just
you take king of foreign
yeah Queen G6 I took yeah
he takes king of four can
I
um
yeah I think you might be yeah bacon
we're going to kick you out because
we've got another beautiful interview
coming in yeah it's all right
and here I am going to look at this
position that John currently has
as this is an amazing game
King G7 G2 oops sorry that's my analysis
I have to
have to refresh
hey welcome welcome nice please take a
seat we're just looking at the one
remaining game this queen ending Queen
endings
uh the Soviets
they explained that chess
has four phases four phases
opening middle game end game
the fourth phase was Queen endings
because in the first three phases you
have rules I'm upon up and so on and so
on but in the fourth phase Queen endings
you could be three pawns up and
completely losing because with the my
one pass Fawn yeah today right so Queen
endings
are really strange and today we know for
example that two ponds two connected
past pawns and a queen versus another
queen is a draw it's like it's crazy
it's like these these table bases what
they teach us congratulations today you
have won a wonderful game what happened
yeah I was not expecting the French at
all but uh yes he was mainly open
Sicilian night of player but he but you
know he played it yeah Championship
right yeah I saw it then
so it wasn't completely a surprise yeah
okay
and the variation you chose with Bishop
D2 that's a little bit off the beaten I
mean it's a it's a known variation yeah
but it's not what we'd say A3 is yeah it
is more popular than normally so did you
prepare this specifically for your
opponent or just in general it's your
yeah in general I prepared and when you
played the French I was like okay let's
try this okay uh tell me when uh more or
less you're in or out of preparation so
far it's still prep it's all pretty to
be honest like after hitch fire at six
at all like I was out that was it yeah
yeah I was not uh because I did not see
it before the game like I was not that
till this I was like okay but after this
I was like on my own okay so it's funny
that you should say uh to be honest
because then it suggests well you can be
dishonestly dishonest uh seven I can I
kind of surprised you everything okay
no I I saw this yeah and I thought it
was a very good move like yes ideas like
to bring the king out and
or just to tuck it away I actually
thought his intention with King D7 was
to bring his Queen to H7 yeah I've seen
this idea some game you know with the
queen going to B8 and A7 and I
remembered that idea I was like thinking
about it but
he said I think quinjet he was afraid of
some Rook F3 I think okay
okay and he cannot really move his Queen
to at seven or but here I thought Queen
at seven was possible because of this
queen E4 and queen H4 tactics maybe oops
it's true it's true Rook F3 has not
stopped it I actually thought Queen a G8
was his right move I thought and you
could tell me if I'm wrong that after G5
you have a lovely position now it's very
very good for you did you like your
position after the move G5 yeah I liked
it because of course jifa is a weakening
move and I was trying to create more
weakness and yeah here's itself I think
he has to push G4 H5 because right and
when he pushes gifa and it's like my
knight gets a wonderful Square on G4 and
that's exactly exactly here uh
I don't know if you have that expression
in India here it felt like one-way
traffic
all your all your visas are going and
blacks pieces are rather stuck yeah uh
Knight F5 Knight G4
tell me uh your your views when did the
critical moment comes up
G3 is a nice move yeah G3 I wanted to
stop Knight H4 because it was
at some points you know Knight H4 and
when I cannot play G3 and F4 also I did
not want to
push too early so I wanted to prepare it
first so I played G3 stopping any ideas
but he played this Rook CG here maybe a
little bit tricky because he's threading
night H4 now
ah
yeah nice
and then there's a hidden tactic yeah I
mean I touch so maybe I can still go
King E2 I think like even if he plays
Knight H4 now
but now I cannot cancel so right yeah
it's
okay Rook
g86 Queen E2 but now you're starting to
get ready for the big
one day you're going to play G4 and F4
I'm not sure in which order yeah but
you're gonna get it going
and
perfectly timed
and here I I just feel it feels like
you're winning yeah I think here it's so
I did not understand this gf4 at all
like
I mean it just it's just losing upon and
okay maybe he thought he he said maybe
he could block it with Knight G6 but uh
of course I got this Knight Edge fan you
know Bishop G5 then
maybe he could have kept the position
like that but even if if even if you
play something like Knight season so
let's say like I can just take FG fair
play Rook of one and
exchange the books and bring the other
Rook to the file and I think should be
meaning for me yeah feels it uh but
unfortunately as you just said GF Knight
F4 there goes the pawn and it's not just
the pawn it's like you know normally
speaking you know I sacrifice I give up
on I get some play
there's no play I mean in fact E6 is
actually vulnerable so
everything just I mean it's I I don't
want to loud your play too much but it's
like one of those things everything's
just like perfectly falls into place
it's just like it every move you've
played is kind of a link in a chain uh
at this point you have different ways of
winning I think yeah you can just choose
your your fashion this is a nice one
beautiful a beautiful Play
Congratulations just for our audience
please just introduce yourself and tell
us a little bit about yourself and yeah
I am Bruno I am from India I'm 16 years
old and
and later 25.88 yeah
you know when I was 16 I was struggling
to become a master 2200. what did you
say you're ready what 25 18.
nice and a grand master yeah and uh
what's your
um how do you say
Ambitions uh further I mean you're
coming from a country India who were the
talents are just going explosive you
want to be a part of that group yeah
yeah I mean the ultimate goal is to
become the world champion of course yeah
that is
and yeah I'm just trying to play my good
chess in the tournaments and not think
about the results yeah right well this
is an indication of what's to come I
would be afraid if I was in the
competition I'm happy to be at the
commentators chair come again thank you
it was lovely thank you so much as we
have one game uh remaining and we're
going to go to that game that's the
queen ending the fifth phase runic
versus John Burke
and when we left it we had this really
spectacular move King G7 loved it
gf3 Queen G5 check
Queen takes and the whole idea
is that any Queen takes B6 will get us
into a three versus two check
and we're up to date welcome
welcome back Megan did you see the young
man 16 years old
[Music]
he reminds me of my youth like
ah
was it the 18th century
wow wow okay uh but very very impressive
we're just jumping into this uh ending
of John oh yes sir as we talked about
King G7 yes and behind the scenes I got
a minute to analyze it okay look at tell
us about the engine says King justavan
actually is not a good move it's not
yeah as with science King Giselle if we
had to move the queen right so Queen A1
and text on G2 was better for black
queen G Queen A1 and take take on G2 and
just threatening
mate so we take that's a check that's
the check King G7 or F6 doesn't matter
we're going to be forced to take on G2
we're going to get this ending right
yeah but just a queen E3 you can like
you can H7 so usually oh okay apologies
uh Queen yes you're right King H2 takes
on G2 takes on Gia check King here takes
on G2 no
yes and now just take on a on it and
we're in that same ending and D5 is
still hanging right yes yes
Queen E4 yes
so an unpleasant ending let me just
refresh because it's kind of getting
that too right he's getting the same
ending with the difference is that we've
had to commit the pawn to F5 maybe uh
there are reasons also it's easier to
hold F3 and H3 pawns than D5 and H3
pawns correct there are reasons why we
don't want the pawn on F3
and that's a very good move right there
because that just kind of cozies up to
these two how are you going to protect
both
not going to be easy well uh here I'll
just I'll just leave this position with
the following thought as I was
explaining to Our Guest that there the
the the Soviets said there are four
phases of chess four phases openings
middle games and endings
but the fourth phase
Queen endings belonged in its own space
its own Galaxy its own Universe because
all of those rules that worked for the
first three phases you could toss them
up
like you could be two pawns up but if my
past Pawn was the furthest
I'm winning and because of the
possibilities of Perpetual checks all
the time
the material count is always super super
strange this game is going to take us a
long while so we're going to actually
sign off I'm gonna I'm gonna tell you it
was great at working but before we leave
we want to give a big shout out to our
audience thank you so much for joining
us tell your friends where you're
hanging out we're going to be hanging
out for the next eight rounds and let's
remind our viewers of the standings of
uh this first round of play beg him do
the other group a province is the solo
leader it was a great win against a very
strong opponent which is a vimanyu
Mishra and then usage
first Benjamin book around
Nicole's Theodore and ronak and John
Burke are still playing in abhimanyu
mistress zero points so far and in group
b where all of the games have been
completed and we three decisive games
which was great and Brandon Jacobson
Simeon lemon
Chandra so far scored full points elshon
Andrew Hong but suren Aram called yeah
Armani Kalyan sorry
and Alexander Wonderland Justin Wong and
unfortunately also welcome to the
Salvage lost their games today
absolutely and again everyone join us
tomorrow at 4 00 PM central time here in
St Louis and in the meanwhile we wish
you a very good evening tomorrow thank
you great I loved it was a nice day nice
day yes yeah it was a great day okay
this has been a presentation of the St
Louis chess club any reproduction or
distribution of this content without the
express written consent of the St Louis
chess club is prohibited